Поняття «паром» існує допоки є люди,
які пам'ятають це.
Цей об'єкт 1984 року виробництва.
За 200 років ми сильно вдосконалили все.
Раніше цей паром був менший,
ці пантони були не із заліза, а з дубових дощок.
Вони були у вигляді корита:
верх незашитий, балки лежали,
тому що тільки підвода їхала.
А ми за сто років дерев'яні балки замінили на залізні,
і замість мотузки конопляної повісили катанку.
Найближчі сто років ми плануємо навіть мотор обладнати.
У 1990 році почав розвалюватися СРСР,
я працював у міжколгоспбуді камінщиком.
Був перший у черзі на квартиру.
Одружився одразу після армії.
Дітей не було: мені по праву
мали надати однокімнатну.
А всі хотіли 2 чи 3-кімнатну.
У тому будинки, де мала бути квартира,
ми почали фундамент робити.
А потім кажуть: «Тікай».
Будинок так і залишився,
перспективи там ніякої  не було:
або брати кельму та їхати у Моску
на заробітки, або тут працювати.
Восени допрацював. Хату купили і переїхали у село.
А тоді дійшло до того,
що поромники, які тут працювали,
по десять годин отам лежали.
Пором плавав сам. Були скандали.
І голова вирішив їх усіх трьох
замінити на молодих-перспективних.
І я потрапив у ту фазу. І так і залишився.
Хоча з першого екіпажу трьох людей
залишився тільки я.
Один протримався місяць, інший — два.
Кишеня грошей, влада необмежена
і щедрі люди —  і все.
Існує правило щодо грошей.
Є дві категорії громадян, яких я перевожу:
це місцеві, жителі Пекарівської сільської ради.
Це чотири села.
Місцеві платять і 50 %.
А пішоходам і велосипедистам я дозволяю не платити.
Якщо людина хоче зекономити, то будь ласка.
У нас паром найвищої якості: дошки з мореного дубу.
Ви знаєте, скільки коштує моренний дуб?
Дорого. Тисячі євро.
Власність громадська. Він був колгоспним.
Коли розвалювалися колгоспи,
щоб не було ніякої монополії,
щоб передати на баланс сільської ради,
виділили майно: пором, комбайн, трактор...
Інше люди не захотіли брати.
На пороми тоді оголосили конкурс.
Листи, конверти, сейфи...
Усе серйозно для нас було, що жах.
Ми конкурс той виграли.
І оце вже дев'ятий рік в оренді.
Специфіка руху: у суботу ті,
що їдуть на базар, їдуть рано,
а ті, що їдуть з міста у село по торби, — близько 10.
Поки прокинуться, зберуться.
Треба банки приготувати.
У село тару треба вести, щоб здавати,
бо не наллють тоді молока, сметани.
Скажуть, банок уже нема: усі вивозили.
І до години десятої знову відновлюється рух.
Усе переправляв.
Танків та БТР-ів не переправляв.
БТР приїхав. Широка колісна база —
і не поміщається на пором.
Довелося повернути назад.
Коли «заворуха» почалася, наші генерали побачили,
що їхні карти ще з 1940-х років.
Там написано, що тут міст стоїть.
Вони кинулися, а воно — не так.
Вони послали з розвідбату.
Тут моталися хлопці БТР-ом.
і звіряли їхні карти з реальним життям.
Ставили свої позначки,
що на поромі тут можна
перевезти машину вагою до 15 т.
БТР, танки не вміщаються.
Готувалися до того, що і тут війна почнеться.
А все решту ми перевозимо.
І корів, і коней...
Зараз усе цивілізовано.
Раніше були приварені такі «вуха».
Засували оці задвижки дубові,
і заганяли табун корів.
Вони заходили, робили «красиву площадку».
Після них пів дня відром треба було змивати. [Cміється]
Було таке: приїхали,
поромщик говорить тільки два слова.
Його розібрати важко.
Хлопці  вирішили, що самостійно переїхати треба.
Воно відв'язали пором, пливуть.
А він встав  — і канат відпустив.
І їх віднесло туди в сторону. Причалити не можуть.
Він лежить спить, а вони тут гукають-сидять.
Як це без поромника їхати? [Cміється]
Так от, розповідаю секрет давніх поромників.
Треба було привести чвертку горілки.
У ті часи тут, у Сосниці,
у кожному районі випускали саморобне вино.
Його називали у народі «Мушинське».
Коштувало 80 копійок.
Привозиш пляшку «Мушинського»,
поромщик тебе запитує:
«Ну що? Прийшов чи приїхав?»
Якщо кажеш: «Прийшов», то зараз-зараз, чекай.
Пішов. Ліг і дрімає.
Якщо приїхав — заходь.
Заходить.
Відкривається вино, наливається у стакан.
Випили по склянці —  і поїхали.
Я коли почав робити, було таке:
рубль за пороми це були не гроші,
а як приїхав з чекушкою,
значить — уважив поромника,
і тоді тобі зайвих питань не ставлять — перевозять.
Зараз мені навіть ніхто і не пропонує.
Є тільки одна-дві людини,
які приїжджають до мене з пляшкою горілки.
Але це люди, які живуть у Москві, куми.
Я кажу:  «Нащо ти привіз? Знаєш, що я не випиваю».
«Ну традиція. Десь на річку поїдемо,
можеш "по-молодості"
пляшку моєї горілки "викинути"».
Він каже: «Тепер я буду тобі возити». Колись так сказав.
Я кажу: «Я не проти — возити». Так він зберігає традицію.
А інші питання про горілку не знають.
Хоча той, хто плавав на паромі у ті часи,
от він знає, що таке «Прийшов чи приїхав?»
[сміється]